[Musique]
elle est arrivée par ce chemin à
l'automne 44 silhouettes noires d'un
oiseau de mauvaise augure à son bord
champ brailler 28 ans et camille lucie
39 ans leur vie va s'arrêter là au pied
du salbert
[Musique]
les saisons passent et qui ont enseveli
les hommes et leur histoire mais des
sentinelles sont toujours là cette croix
dressant lisière de forêt cette témoin
muet qu'il a fallu relever et arracher à
leur silence pour jean tout commence en
quand vous découvrez des croix sur la
santé qui en plus la gr 5 à sentiers de
promenade
s'il ya eu forcément une histoire et on
peut pas oublier l'histoire c'est
impossible il faut chercher ce qui s'est
passé on mène une enquête en fait au
début on recherche
on va dire comme ça pour trouver des
faits mais finalement qu'on a des faits
on veut en savoir plus
tout savoir sur ce 11 septembre 1944
penchant camille mais aussi georges
lucien marcel et roger sont arrêtés dans
un café de belfort 74 ans qu leur mort
jean bouclet résume le destin de huit
résistants après une interminable plongé
de 400 heures dans les archives jusqu'à
mettre la main sur les procès-verbaux
originaux dressé par la milice des faits
rien que des faits au mot près qu'il
décide de consigner dans un documentaire
en 50 minutes tout sera dit la
collaboration la trahison l'héroïsme le
désarroi la douleur aussi
on a réussi à retourner dans les vrais
lieux d'époque avec le même nombre de
personnes jusqu'à leur nom aux véhicules
aux endroits tout et au millimètre près
respectées par rapport à l'histoire de
ce qui s'est passé sur ces lieux ce
souci de réalisme l'association
souviens-toi 1944 il tenait sans
exagérer mais sans édulcorer non plus
les scènes de torture ont été les plus
éprouvantes non arrestation c'est c'est
rien à côté de ce qui s'est passé par la
suite
quand il ya eu l'interrogatoire qui a
été très très durs qu'a duré plusieurs
semaines
et puis au moment de l'exécution comment
ça s'est passé dans les moindres détails
ça a été moi j'ai pense encore fait
prenant pour pour les gens pour les
personnes qu'on convaincu ce à quoi mais
ça leur rend hommage aussi à la fois
tourné sur le temps libre des bénévoles
le dvd sera prêt en septembre son ennemi
revanche le travail de reconstitution
s'achèvera donc bientôt
mais l'histoire sont toujours la poudre
et le soufre
j'ai reçu quand même aussi deux coups de
fil anonymes qui me disait justement de
laisser le passé où il était qu'il
fallait pas remonter les informations du
passé mais c'est le contraire justement
il ne faut pas oublier ces gens là ils
sont morts pour notre liberté pour qu'on
soit libre aujourd'hui les dépouilles
des fusils ont été jetés dans des fosses
anonyme tout ce qu'il reste de leur
calvaire
ce sont ces croix et une poignée de
douilles comme une mise en garde outre
tombe des oubliés du salbert